chris rock breaks his silence on the
slap scene around the world
i had like a whole show i wrote before
this weekend
and i'm still kind of processing
what happened
appearing before an enthusiastic crowd
in boston he teased what the future
holds
abc entertainment producer anastasia
williams who was at the show reveals
roth got emotional when the audience
gave him a two-minute standing ovation
as he walked out on stage he wiped away
some tears he was smiling but you could
tell that he was really overcome by the
moment
as the follow continues oscar co-host
wanda sykes was on ellen and said she
was disgusted by the slapping incident
it was sickening it was absolutely i
physically
felt ill and i'm still a little
traumatized by it me too and for them to
let him stay in that room
and enjoy the rest of the show
and accept his award i was like how
gross is this this is just the wrong
message
and now a new video has emerged on tick
tock shot from a few rows behind where
will and jada pinkett smith were sitting
at the oscars it appears to show jada
laughing after will slaps chris
later jada reacts to his comment about
it being the greatest night in the
history of television
meanwhile details about the tense
moments after that infamous slap
continue to come out as the academy
released a statement saying will was
asked to leave but refused to do so and
acknowledge they could have handled the
situation differently but contradicting
that statement tmz has multiple sources
stating academy officials producers on
the show and will's publicist all
discuss what was going to happen next
but they never reached a consensus the
academy has begun disciplinary
proceedings against the oscar winner who
could face a suspension expulsion or
other disciplinary actions when the
board of governors meets again on april
18th and according to the hollywood
reporter there is strong support for
will smith to be either suspended or
expelled from the academy
you